bon alors on choisit qui julie n'est
fait lit ça marche pas comme c'est un
mec si si ça marche comme ça je veux
dire c'est grâce à ça que j'ai réussi à
choisir entre christian étoiles
fonctions oui question de la contre tête
entre eux mais christian oui j'ai hésité
entre trois agressions et jeu ça
pourquoi tu as gagné
pourquoi on est devenus amis non tu veux
pas savoir je revois ton haleine je
voulais pas savoir je travaille je
t'avais prévenu
justement oui ton haleine c'est un
soleil d'été veille
c'est l'odeur de la pluie sur la salve
un jour de canicule
c'est fort c'est raffiné c'est puissant
merci christian dumas déjà à temps
je tomberai plus jamais amoureux tu
jures way masi crash
ça marche pas si tu pense pas qu on
vivait ensemble du faire ensemble
à part baiser elle fait tout ensemble
bien y aller la coloc là
[Musique]
non
je pari qu'a fait je suis désolé je te
j'étais pas fait mal quand tu me couvre
mec j'ai pas envie que cette fille avec
qui j'ai couché deux fois vienne sq le
bordel dans notre amitié voilà ce que
c'est juste du cul bonhomme quoi et
webone lançant ça fait des semaines qui
découchent oh mais c'est bien ça c'était
une vie sexuelle épanouie c'est
malheureusement plus avec christophe
nous on expérimente région par d'autres
choses que tu es un cachet une compote
qui fait quoi tu parles acquis à
personne blake n'a même pas que ce soit
la clé du coup je sais à qui tu es
[Musique]
bon alors on choisit qui julie n'est
fini qu'est ce que t'as foutu vincent
chat et à la chair était là depuis débat
comme ça je fais les bris pence elle a
trois ans je sais
[Musique]
une tête elle est horrible